I wasn't sure I was going to do this
video
but
Beverly Crusher is in horrific human
being
literally the worst
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
so yes I I was I'm just gonna do this
video really quickly because I'm
pronounced stop thinking about it since
I watched the third episode of Star Trek
Picard but Beverly Crusher is literally
the worst person on Earth she's awful
and I'm going to very quickly explain
why
so she did not tell Jean-Luc Picard
somebody she supposedly trusts more than
anybody and loves
that for 20 years he had a son
now we have the immediate that's just
awful thing but then she comes up with
an excuse she says I couldn't tell you I
couldn't with tears in her eyes because
after I got Jiggy and we got pregnant
um within two months there was like
three or four attempts on your life
and um I just knew that any son of
Jean-Luc Picard would have a Target on
his back
it's a lame excuse right for a couple of
reasons
this is the Federation
Jean-Luc Picard yes
he was at risk and yes people kept
trying to kill him
but at the same time they could have
protected him all right
um all wealthy people have Targets on
their back but we protect them and I
could say this is the Federation so they
could have protected him
look look
I'm pregnant it's yours but I'm scared
for him because I need to protect him
and I can't protect Jean-Luc Picard's
son so I want you to stay out of the way
I don't want you to be involved
and Jean-Luc my wife said no
but he might have said yes and he might
have said well I'll watch him from a
distance
she then know Beverly just another
crappy move and
um while she's telling Jean-Luc that it
was her decision she then says
when he was old enough I told him and he
didn't want anything to do with you
which I'm sure is her sort of thinking
you know I I didn't I'm not a horrible
horrible person as soon as you're old
enough and I think that's the writers
trying to like make out that she's not
an awful human being but all I'm
thinking is she's blaming Jack it's an
apricot's going oh well great so you
didn't want me anything to do with him
now he didn't want anything to do with
me either oh thanks honestly it's
just awful but the real thing that
really annoys me the the ghost Beyond
her just being an awful human being can
going beyond that
she was there when Jean-Luc got the news
about his family dying
his brother and it was Renee I think was
his name the lad
she was there and saw how destroyed
Jean-Luc was when he realized the family
name was going to die with him
she was there she saw how devastated he
was during the movie generations and she
did this anyway
now I would say that she's incredibly
selfish
um she then though
goes I mean this is a bit that makes any
sense at all she sends him to school in
England
so okay they're in England for ages
great and he picked up the English
accent great
um Sean Luke Picard is French and he's
got an English accent
um but she then leads Jack Crusher her
son into a life of crime
we saw last week Jean-Luc list off his
crimes and he's wanted within the
Federation and outside of the Federation
for loads of things they were weapons
smuggling for God's sake which I don't
know about you but I don't think is a
particularly safe working environment
is wanted for at least one murder even
though he said well the guy might just
be
just
you cannot say that you're trying to
protect your son so I'm going to keep
you away from your father and then lead
him into a life of crime something that
in last week's episode he said she
encouraged
um she he said when she wasn't behind me
kicking my ass she was stood next to me
because Jean-Luc actually says I know
you're a lie now because Beverly
wouldn't do that otherwise Beverly you
maybe not because I'm thinking the
Beverly We Now know is an awful human
being and I'm pretty sure she would
maybe she was making money off the poor
kid we don't know don't we she did this
she could be capable of anything
I will say by now I'm really really
enjoying Picard season three I think
it's fantastic I was gutted when the
episode ended today I'm just loving it
but there are quite a few silly mistakes
and I think this was one of those silly
mistakes last week they had the silly
mistake that it started off with two
weeks ago and then they go on to
repeatedly say that this happened at
least two months ago and like continuity
error idiots
the first week we had that code word
that there was no way Jean-Luc Picard
could have known even though he should
have known because actually she was um
he should have read like the reports and
stuff
and then
um
this week we've got this thing where it
just makes Beverly up to be a horrific
human being
so guys get in the comments tell me what
you think though is definitely kusher
awful or is am I just overreacting I
don't know but I'm sorry
she comes across as a horrific human
being to me but get in the comments tell
me what you think just a quick fun video
anyway I am enjoying it honestly it's
brilliant but this storyline is
irritating me slightly I don't know why
they just didn't write it in anyway
if you're new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification and
do all that it's just a thumbs up and
everything thanks very much I'll see you
next time keep watching Star Trek even
though I'm bitching about it it's great
honestly
[Music]